Why is it the greatest challenge facing
both parties?
Fundamental change.
You can live in a lot of moments in
American history where the is you're
born into and the world's you governor
that vastly different and they're always
different 30 or 40 years past.
You know,
things are gonna change in a country.
But uh,
but that said,
you know,
you can there if you were,
if you were born at a certain point in
the 20th century after,
you know,
the,
after the Great Depression and you were
governing in the 1960s or 1970s,
you know,
the world was,
the economy was pretty much the economy
it was supposed to be.
It was run by an industrial engine.
The world was still divvied up among
states who did,
you know,
menaced each other only or,
sign treaties and didn't manage each
other.
I mean,
the world was pretty much the one.
You had telephones and you had
television,
you had nicer televisions and you had
cable TV.
But people were still communicating with
one another and much the same way.
And they were still posting letters by
hand and sending them in a mailbox,
you know?
Uh,
and then you have a moment like this
where,
uh,
where the world is just vastly different
than it was 30,
40 years ago.
And in a sense,
we're caught between moments,
right?
We're in between this industrial age and
what comes next because we still have
vestiges one foot in the past,
vestiges of the past and one foot there
and one foot in the future.
So the challenge for the Democratic
Party or any party has to lead the way
into that future is to articulate what,
what government and the economic engine
and foreign policy of a country are
going to look like.
Uh,
in the era where none of those things
are operable anymore,
when the economy is nonindustrial
driven,
where people communicate with each other
all over the world in a flash,
right,
where people expect to have options and
choices in their lives where the threats
that,
uh,
affect the world are not necessarily
states to states,
but a bunch of people who can
communicate on the Internet and do a
great deal more damage than a general in
some country.
Can.
You know,
this is,
this is a whole new landscape and when
I'm coming around to the view that,
um,
it's too much to ask,
it's just too much to ask of a
generation,
uh,
born into a different world to govern in
this one.
I think the baby boom generation has
done what it can.
Uh,
um,
I,
I don't,
I don't indict them as,
you know,
selfish,
worthless people.
I just think it's,
it may have been just too much to ask a
generation born in the 1950s to figure
out how to govern in the,
in the year 2007 or 2008.
And I,
I'm not,
I'm coming around to the view that
leadership and real leadership and real
change and real evolution of government,
we'll,
we'll have to wait for another
generation.